why do you make movies for less than 50
000
i think most people that make movies for
less than 50 000 are making it just like
me because that's that's
that's what we
have to work with you know or that's
what we can raise i mean i would uh i
would feel much more
comfortable like like as far as like
production goes working around 200 000
or 300 000. you know making a 50 000
movie is tough no matter how you cut it
no matter what the scale of it is trying
to pay people fair rates and like it's
it's next to impossible
so
i make 50 000 movies for one because
that's
like that's the ceiling of what
well close to the ceiling of what i can
raise myself or pay for myself you know
anything beyond that it starts getting a
little like hairier you know
so and then as far as returns
like
to be perfectly honest i like i wouldn't
feel 100 comfortable right now taking a
hundred thousand dollars on a movie i
wouldn't be positive i could return that
back
50 000 for the right movie i i'm
80 90 sure i can return that back or at
least most of it 100 i don't know
when you say the right movie are we
talking narrative are we talking
documentary i it could be narrative or
documentary when i say right movie i
mean like you know the
a gen
genre that's doing well in the market
um a
you know a
you know a scale that you know i think
would work at that budget level you know
for example i'm getting ready to do a
horror movie and it's called craving uh
budgets right around you know 50 60 000
and you know it's a it's a siege pitcher
takes place mostly in one location
it has some incredible creature effects
and right now as far as independent
films go independent horror movies
creature stuff is doing really well and
if your creature is good like it can do
really well like let's let's just say
for example the movie kind of turned out
mediocre but those monster things are
all really good like that movie can
still like you know make that budget
back and then some based off the monster
it's almost like
what name talent was to you know horror
movies five years ago you know the
monster becomes the name
you know so if you think that a movie is
over 50 000 then you realize i may have
to take
a producer's money and i don't want to
add that stress
i don't want to have to
[Music]
i mean that's a lot of stress on
someone's shoulders to be accountable
for that yeah so so the 50 000 is a safe
place for you because you know you can
do that on your own yes yeah and and and
also
just to start
thinking about it on a on a backend way
and you'll hear a lot of filmmakers say
hey if you don't get paid up front
you're not going to get paid and you
know maybe if you're a dp or director
for hire that's true but has an
entrepreneurial producer
you're making every your back end is
everything you know so if i make if i
have a 50 000 movie and say a producer
comes to me tomorrow and they want to
put in 50 000 so now it's a 100 000
movie
how much back end do i have to give to
that producer
you know
they're putting in 50 of the budget so
let's just say for the sake of argument
you're gonna have to give them
you know half of the back end you know
50
and how much more is that movie actually
going to make in the market at 100 000
as opposed to 50
is it enough that that 50 is worth it
because i make my living off of my back
end so if i'm losing half of my back end
is the movie gonna make more than fifty
percent higher
then you gotta have you gotta think
about stuff like that you know and in
this particular case
like unless
you know i guess i guess maybe at 50
maybe maybe if i put in like a like a
bigger name actor like if i put 25 of it
and hired like tony todd or something
like that
maybe that would help it but i i
honestly don't know um you know i have a
friend who just did uh did a horror
movie a couple years ago and had some
two
like pretty good like you know like
upper level like b actors should have
the movie should have done gangbusters
and it didn't you know
so if 50 is just i i think 50 is a safer
bet
right and are these usually films that
are shot in one location
no um
although
like
so i did one called the other side um
back in 2014 and it had
like maybe 12 locations but
like we shot a good chunk of it in this
compound
where you know it was like this person
they had a house and they had a garage
and they had like an office and you know
we we made like six locations out of
that one you know and as far as like on
independent stuff people say this all
the time like you know
make it a one location shoot you know
like that's that's the way to save all
your budget
it's only going to save so much because
a shoot day is a shoot day like a shoot
day costs a production what a shoot day
cost of production
yes you're going to lose some time if
you're constantly company moving but you
know on an nd on average you know you're
spending i don't know five or six
thousand a day
so
as long as your company moves are
you know uh
structured to where you know you're on
one location for that whole day and then
maybe another location for another three
days and then one day at another
location but you're not doing like
midday company moves
it it's
you're not gonna save a ton of money on
the single location a little bit but not
not a ton like you might on a six day
shoot
you might you might lose a half a day in
the company moves that split across six
days so like it's it's really not that
much not much of a save
and for the 50 000 budget are you
typically the editor
yes yes
and the reason being i'm not one of
those people like i have to edit
everything
but
you know i've been editing now for
20 years
and you know at 50 000
you know you're gonna be able to pay an
editor you know like five or six you
know maybe 10 000 tops
like and i don't feel like i'm gonna
find an editor for ten thousand dollars
or five thousand dollars that's as good
as me not to be egocentric about it but
i i it's totally a practical decision if
i you know if i had another 25 000
to you know pay a full post team i would
but i don't so i do it
can we break down this 50 000 budget
sure and help us understand like where
are you spending that money okay yeah
yeah
so
like i'll do like a kind of a generic
like like breakdown of a 50 000
movie so i'll talk a little bit about
craving because i'm just doing that now
so um
oh gosh it's hard without it in front of
me but um so
yeah probably about
on craving
10 000
um went for location uh right right off
the bat we needed uh like a warehouse
space uh two to three thousand square
feet and we have to build a set
so you know we're gonna spend um i can't
say exactly how much on the rental and
then 5 000 on the uh
the building of the the bar set which is
the main location and then um there's
some money in lodging because uh it
looks like we're gonna shoot in palmdale
so i'm gonna have to put people up there
oh and just so this is all in california
yeah this one's gonna be in california
so we're spending 10k on the location um
we're spending it's a it's a bigger cast
than i typically work with i think we're
i think we're 10 or 12 uh like
major roles in it and so we're spending
about twelve thousand dollars on cast
and that's not including name talent
yeah include the three name actors and
that's closer to 20.
and then um
[Music]
we're spending
we're
we're spending 5 000 on
effects materials
and we've already i'm not counting this
as part of the 50 but we'd already spent
almost uh 10 000
on monster materials uh prior to the
crowdfunder
um and then but we'll just we'll just
say the the five and so that puts us
like what 35
and then we're spending
about
let's see three 300 a day 300 a day on
catering and another 200 a day on crafty
um and then the rest of it's all in crew
and on crew on like on indies now i you
know i start my base pay at 200 a day
nothing under i'm sorry 211 a day it's
like uh california i think like minimum
wage in 12 hours and ends up at 211 but
then key positions get a little bit more
so like the dp might make 350 or 400 or
sound might make more but for the most
part right around that 211 mark and
we'll do this with a
skeleton crew you know it'll be it'll be
a dp she'll be
she'll be running her own camera
including focus
um there'll be a
secondary camera
and when the secondary camera is not in
operation that person's also like the
the swing so their operator slash swing
and then uh the third person's like the
gaffer and then um and then there's a uh
uh dit that's also our script supervisor
and you know stuff like that you know um
there'll be makeup um but it'll be
one person hair and makeup and then our
effects guy who does some makeup as well
we'll augment some of that
and tell me again i'm sorry how long of
shoot is this so this one is
10 days i believe i'm still kind of
scheduling it out the the bar which is
the bulk of it is gonna be six days and
then um the exteriors and there's a few
uh
other locations like three or four days
and this food that you're getting it's
from a restaurant or these are caterers
coming no so like in this case i'm i'm
very lucky with this and the fact that
my my niece is a professional caterer
she lives in indiana and my my she's
gonna she's doing this one as a favor so
i'm basically flying her out and then
like at 300 a day she could make she
could feed a 20-person crew cast and
crew
two meals for like 200 a day
like she's really like you know we were
the kind of poor that you know we would
spend 20 and you know a family of five
would eat for a week yeah
and where is she making the food oh
she'll do it here so like it's like
she'll fly out um like our kitchen in
canoga park or um we're also if we're
shooting in palmdale um you know we're
gonna rent airbnb so we might have an
airbnb that's set up for the cooking and
then you know we'll have the stuff moved
into the set which is like 10 minutes
away
so post you're basically spending almost
nothing almost nothing okay so what i
like on documentaries i spend i
literally spend nothing i i do it all
like i'm not an expert colorist but i
can i can do it well enough
i'm real i'm pretty darn good with sound
design and mix the only thing i can't
really do myself is like a good 5.1
but i know several people to where i can
get it done very affordably so like on
this movie like you know i want it to be
it's a little bit higher profile than a
lot of the docs that i do so i will most
likely hire a colorist and a
sound mixer and that money has not yet
been raised so like you know like i had
the crowdfunding consultant for this and
he said you know after you shoot the
movie you know no sooner than june we'll
do a post production crowdfunder for it
and he said we could expect you know
between
20 and 30 percent of what we raised
before for post so we're looking at
maybe 15 or 20 000
and not to jinx it but let's suppose
you're out there and you need to go a
day over
let's i mean yeah i'm doing totally
totally there could be a hail storm
okay yeah so
is there money in reserves or you know i
can pull from here my own sources yes
okay so there's not
like the way a lot of indies work is
like you i don't have an official
contingency in the budget but i have
money from you know an outside source
that i can go to if something like that
were to happen
you know or even you know going a little
bit deeper into my own pockets if i have
to
so you're prepared
yeah rainy day yeah right yeah exactly
so to speak okay that's good